how's Tyler enjoying the beautiful Gold  cars I I'm not gonna answer that that's  Araya  that's Tom Hiddleston publicly  addressing his relationship with Taylor  Swift for the first time since the pair  started dating in a new interview with  Australia's 9 News the actor didn't  reveal much but seemed to be in a great  mood what do you and your girlfriend  looking forward to doing on the Gold  Coast I don't know it's just good to be  back it's been a whirlwind romance for  the couples who were first spotted  kissing by the beach in Rhode Island  last month since then they've taken  their love to England Italy and now  Australia where the 35 year old is  filming thor ragnarok safe to say if  things are moving swiftly